Kathie Lee's last day at the today's
show is coming up in April what survived
like there right now well I think we're
just kind of ignoring it that maybe
she'll change your mind you know it's
it's going to be very bittersweet but
she has been such a great part of part
of today's I don't want to think about
it tell us that she's planning the
Queen's Jubilee of send-offs for her yes
any details you can share I have no idea
i i I've gotten through my career by not
knowing things I I like taught not to
know I like to be surprised like with
everybody else people still want you to
maybe take her seat next to Jota no no
look I got my hands full
during the first three hours of today
and I listen if they need me to fill in
I'm happy to but I think I think three
hours of Al Roker is more than anybody
really wants to say what will you miss
most about caffeine I just you know her
her laugh and her sense of humor and her
faith you know she's she's a really
great combination of live broadcasting
of a real faith and a wicked sense of
humor did she teach you anything over
the years just to be just to be yourself
you know she's that's one great thing
about Kathie Lee is that she doesn't she
didn't she kind of teaches by doing not
by telling you who do you think should
replace her if not you I I don't know I
you know what that's it I let it I let
the folks in the upper office figure
that it's I just I just show up I feel
like your book adaptations have become
such a staple at a hallmark movie in
mysteries thank you yeah we're very
excited about it we just I was just up
in Vancouver we were doing the fifth one
we're writing the script for the six and
they just approved to seventh so it's
it's fun the people like Billy blessing
love Holly and people love Holly
Robinson Peete
I know that you've done cameos and of
course you made your Broadway debut in
October more acting in your future I
don't know you know I I just kind of
show up you know if somebody says hey
you want to come and do this yeah sure
why not
there's a Greek it's a free trip and
there's a craft service table which is
kind of cool so it's all it's all good
it's all good